>>> ALL RIGHT, THERE ARE LESS
THAN THREE HOURS BEFORE THE
FIRST POLLS CLOSE, IN LESS THAN
2 HOURS WE'LL GET OUR FIRST LOOK
AT HOW PEOPLE VOTED AND WHY.
THE FIRST EXIT POLLS.
THIS COMES AS OFFICIALS HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING MISINFORMATION AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ALL DAY.
LOOK YOU HOPE THESE THINGS DON'T
BREAK OUT INTO THE MAINSTREAM,
THEY CAN NIP THIS IN THE BUD AND
GET THE ANSWERS PEOPLE NEED AND
THE TRANSPARENCY WHAT CAN YOU
TELL US ABOUT ONE OF THESE CASES
OF MISINFORMATION.
>> VERY SIMILAR TO 2020 ELECTION
WHERE WE'RE SEEING VIDEOS --
ISSUES ARE GOING TO ARISE AT THE
POLLS, THERE ARE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CITIES, TOWNSHIPS,
POLLING LOCATIONS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, WE HAVE VIDEO FROM THIS
MORNING IN MARICOPA COUNTY, A
POLL WORKER THERE EXPLAINING
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH A
TABULATION MACHINE, AFTER PEOPLE
GO VOTE THEY CAN PUT THEIR VOTE
INTO THE TABULATION MACHINE IT
WASN'T READING SOME BALLOTS THIS
MORNING BUT YOU'RE ABLE TO PUT
YOUR VOTE INTO A SECURE BOX NEXT
TO THE MACHINE AND IT WOULD BE
BROUGHT TO BE COUNTED TONIGHT AN
ISSUE THAT WAS ALL RESOLVED NOW
ACROSS SOCIAL MEDIA THE VIDEO OF
THAT HAS BEEN VIEWED MORE THAN 3
MILLION TIMES BUT IT'S BEING
SHARED IN THE CONTEXT AS THOUGH
THIS THIS IS EVIDENCE THAT FRAUD
IS HAPPENING IN MARICOPA COUNTY
IN ARIZONA, THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
THE CASE.
LISTEN TO THESE ELECTION
OFFICIALS.
>> NO ONE IS BEING
DISENFRANCHISED THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT THING AND NONE OF THIS
INDICATES ANY FRAUD OR ANYTHING
OF THAT SORT, THIS IS A
TECHNICAL ISSUE.
>> AND LOOK, JUST AS BILL GATES
WAS SAYING THERE, THEY'RE DOING
THEIR BEST TO EXPLAIN IT, WHAT
WE'RE SEEING EVERYTHING GETS
CLASSIFIED AS FRAUD.
>> IMMEDIATELY.
WHEN YOU TAKE YOUR BALLOT
BASICALLY YOU FEED IT INTO THAT
THING AND IT'S SUPPOSED TO READ
IT.
THE KEY POINT YOU'RE SAYING WHAT
THEY SAID IT, TAKE IT AND PUT IT
IN THE BOX NEXT TO IT AND WE'LL
FIX THE ISSUE.
WHAT ELSE ARE OFFICIALS SAYING
ABOUT THESE REPORTS?
>> WE HAVE SEEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT POST ABOUT IT ON HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM TODAY.
ONE TWEET FROM THE COUNTY
ITSELF, ADDRESSED TO A
REPUBLICAN ACTIVIST WHO'S SAYING
THERE'S ALL THESE WAITS AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE RESPONSIBLE.
MARICOPA COUNTY SAYING NO PART
OF THIS TWEET BELOW IS ACCURATE.
THE VS. MA SKRORTY OF VOTE
CENTERS ARE SEEING WAIT TIMES
UNDER 30 MINUTES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WOLF, IT'S SO INCREDIBLE TO
THING YOU JUST ONE SHRED OF
UNCERTAINTY AND IT CAN BLOW UP
INTO SOMETHING SO SIGNIFICANT
EVEN WHEN IT'S PROVEN TO BE
UNTRUE.
>> 100%.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JAMIE GANGEL AND MARK
PRESTON ARE BACK WITH ME FOR
MORE PERSPECTIVE.
DO YOU THINK WE'RE GOING ON SEE
CLAIMS OF FRAUD FROM THE RIGHT
EVEN IF THE REPUBLICANS BIND UP
DOING WELL TONIGHT?
>> I THINK YOU HAVE TO OBVIOUSLY
TAKE IT STATE BY STATE AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE PLACE WHERE
IT'S CLOSE ENOUGH THAT PEOPLE
CAN RAISE QUESTIONS AND I THINK
THE THING WE HAVE TO BE AWARE OF
IS TWO YEARS AFTER THE 2020
ELECTION, ARE THERE PROVISIONS
IN PLACE, HAVE THERE BEEN
IMPROVEMENTS AT THAT STATE
ELECTION LEVELS SO THEY CAN
MANAGE THOSE QUESTIONS, THOSE
DOUBTS AND THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO ANY THREATS.
>> MARK, DO YOU THINK MARICOPA
COUNTY'S RESPONSE WHAT HAPPENED
WILL BE ENOUGH TO PUT SOME OF
THESE ACCUSATIONS TO REST?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE ENOUGH BUT IT'S NEEDED.
.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS YOU
HAVE TO GO OUT EXPLAIN -- BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE AND I
KNOW IN POLITICS YOU HAVE TO BE
AS OPAQUE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE NO
ONE EVER TELLS THE TRUTH.
THESE SECRETARIES OF STATE,
ELECTION OFFICIALS AROUND THE
COUNTRY AREN'T MAKING ENORMOUS
SALARIES THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB AND THEY'RE NOT IT
IN FOR PARTISAN REASONS.
LOOK, I THINK WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE PROBLEMS, THE BIG TELL WILL
BE IN ALL OF THE VICTORIES,
THERE WILL BE NO CONCERN, IN
LOSSES THAT'S WHERE THE CONCERN
IS.
>> THAT'S WHERE THE FRAUD IS.
JAMIE, AS WE KNOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
THEY WERE VERY ACTIVE ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL THIS WEEK PUSHING
VERY HARD ON THE IDEA THAT
DEMOCRACY HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES IS ACTUALLY ON THE BALLOT
IN THIS ELECTION, WHAT ROLE DO
THESE VIRAL CONSPIRACY THEORIES
PLAY IN THAT THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY?
>> I THINK THAT COUNTERPOINT
THAT YOU JUST SAID IS EXACTLY
THE PROBLEM, DEMOCRACY IN PERIL
IS NOT JUST A SLOGAN, I MEAN WE
HAVE WATCHED THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
ON JANUARY 6th, THAT SAID,
ELECTION DENIAL IS THE TRUMP
PLAYBOOK AND IT'S BECOME THE
REPUBLICAN PLAYBOOK.
THEY HAVE FOUND IT WORKS FOR
THAT.
WHETHER IT'S DISINFORMATION OR
MISINFORMATION, CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
I CALL THEM LIES.
ELECTION DAY IS NOT EVEN OVER
AND I HAVE HEARD FROM REPUBLICAN
STRATEGIES WHO ARE WORKING IN
SOME OF THESE ELECTIONS AND ONE
OF THEM SAID TO ME, QUOTE, I
JUST KNOW OUR FOLKS ARE GOING TO
BE HOLLERING IN EVERY CLOSE
RACE, IT'S A CONTINUATION OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID IN 2